i've got some interesting tape here
in a repeat performance
jd broke down crying after the bengals
kicker
hit the game-winning field goal here is
actual tape of jd breaking down and it's
a weird cry
[Laughter]
goddamn man
oh [ __ ]
all right stop recording me my nose is
i'm snotting out the storm there's not
even a moment of celebration before he's
like a a mess i hugged the wall
immediately i just collapsed into the
wall and just crying into the wall
he almost swallowed his tongue
the crying continued well into the
post-game ceremony
this is
listen to this icky icky woods
who died
icky woods of course legendary bengals
player known for the icky shuffle
endzone dance but when you saw icky did
you just tear you up well yeah i mean he
was he was there for the last time the
bengals went to the super bowl i'm happy
for jd listen this
howard thanks to you i can never ever
thank you enough for sending my wife and
i to the super bowl and it's like
for somebody to have their team in the
super bowl and jd's team has never won a
super bowl it's like a
once-in-a-lifetime thing well
i um had my representatives call jd i'm
sending him to the super bowl
wow he's very excited about it very
exciting thank you yeah
it was very difficult
to get these tickets
oh yeah
and uh
yeah jd has two tickets who are you
bringing and maybe someone uh from here
to cover me
uh to cover the actions
action yeah yes are you excited about
going to the super bowl yeah of course
thank you very much uh it's uh it's
gonna be an unbelievable experience and
uh
yeah it's it's gonna be crazy when uh
hopefully i'll see the bengals when
they're
first super bowl they're gonna go nuts
if they win oh if i i'll be i i don't
know if i'll stop crying uh you know oh
this will be and people will be around
and see him